it's hard to say the best but the one i
love the most is casablanca
james my favorite part about my job is
being able to be part of all the great
things that the academy does the oscars
the
academy student film awards putting
together a
academy museum of the motion picture
which is going to open in four years
here in los angeles
the governor's awards honoring some of
the greatest
uh people in our industry it's just it's
being a part working with my peers
having a
and having an input into all the great
things the academy does
well thanks moani i'm happy i've got
kisses
what does it take to win an oscar
it takes excellent in your feed
excellence in your field
whether you be a makeup man a
director of photography a production
designer an actor a writer or director
we take very seriously 6 000 of us vote
for 24 different awards we see every
movie and if we haven't seen all the
movies we don't vote in that particular
category
but
it takes excellent you have to be the
best of that year
no george we are staying right here in
hollywood at the new dolby theater
the best picture category will have at
least five it could have as many as ten
my guess is it's going to be somewhere
around seven or eight this year